we have big news maybe in the case of
the death of Trump friend and sex
trafficker Jeffrey Epstein who died
under what I admit our strange and
unusual circumstances while in jail
awaiting trial in what was called a
suicide but quite frankly it sounded odd
from day one even without jumping into
any particular conspiracy theory the New
York chief medical examiner ruled the
death a suicide by hanging back in
August there is this well-known forensic
pathologist named Michael Baden who's
been appearing on television for decades
I remember watching him on Larry King
when I was a kid in the late 90s and he
was interviewed by the folks over at Fox
& Friends and he says the evidence that
he has reviewed is more indicative of
homicide than suicide now I want to look
at pieces of this because while I agree
that there are weird things about the
epstein death I'm gonna be totally
transparent with you I'm not fully in on
the conspiracy theory side I'm not fully
in on the official story makes sense to
me I don't know what happened but I want
us to be savvy and critical consumers of
any assertion that we see in the media
and there is a lot of stuff here that if
you actually pick it apart doesn't make
a lot of sense so let's start with the
first segment from Fox & Friends
well I was asked by the brother the
next-of-kin to be at the autopsy and at
the autopsy on day one they were
findings that were unusual for suicidal
hanging and more consistent with
ligature homicidal strangulation which
included and it was suggested at the
time that he committed suicide by doing
what but by hanging at the time he was
found
allegedly hanging by a homemade ligature
of sheets are you saying you don't think
it was suicide I think that the evidence
points toward homicide rather than
suicide I because there are multiple
three fractures in the hyoid bone the
thyroid cartilage that are very unusual
for suicide and more indicative of
strangulation homicidal strangulation
so Baden says that the autopsy he
observed it
inconclusive whether it was homicide or
suicide initially and then it was later
changed and it's unclear why and that's
a lot of the focus here but that's not
really evidence of anything and it's
important to understand that also a lot
of the framing of this interview is off
brian kilmeade frames this like baden is
like a working a charity case here he
says how did you learn the family needed
your help it's important to understand
that Michael Baden was hired by Jeffrey
Epstein's brother he's in the employ of
Jeffrey Epstein this is not a charity
case and your entire understanding of
what Michael Baden says is different if
you see him as the Good Samaritan with
decades of expertise showing up to help
out someone in need versus he's involved
because he was hired for money
presumably as far as we would be led to
assume by one of the parties that is
involved you have to take that into
account let's continue so you're saying
when you left the examination room they
weren't sure what happened that's right
so what you know this procedure what
happened the interim to get this soso
such a blunt conclusion well a week
later it was changed to homicide the
brother wants to know what did they get
new in that week to make it to homicide
what's your answer to that we don't know
we don't know it's 80 days now right and
the brother feels he's getting a
runaround and to add to it there was a
total breakdown in security the video
cameras in work the guards went to sleep
okay and then so this is sort of a key
thing these broken bones are much at
issue and later he's asked if he's ever
seen fractured bones in the hyoid or
thyroid I think what would the thyroid
it's called something else maybe a
fracture or or damage to it in a
self-inflicted hanging death how hard is
it to commit suicide in prison
very easy and but first in this
situation who if he took the sheets and
stripped and made would have taken a
good half hour or hour to make the
ligature then to go up there at once
you're hanging it's about five minutes
or so that you can have be near dead dr.
Baden though if you know if it you know
the the supper
is that it was a homicide that would
mean cops were in an in on it you know
who opened the door who moved the
cameras always that's right well
terrible allegation it's well the why
were the two guard to guard to sleep in
fifty years of looking death in New York
State then occasionally a guard falls
asleep never our two guards at the same
time the cell the the camera and the
cell watching didn't work the camera in
the hallway to see if anybody came in
and out of his cell didn't work this is
bizarre that his roommate was taken away
so he's all by himself suicide watch was
taking away so yeah the issue you bring
up has to be invest doesn't mean that
this is a homicide right but certainly
it deserves investigation and the
brothers concerned there is no in
basically seen anyone that committed
suicide and we was hanging themselves
with those three broken bones no hanging
does not cause these broken bones and
homicide does are usually to grow to
bones even three is a huge amount of
pressures who was applied so listen I
don't know what to think okay if we step
back for a second Michael Baden was
hired by Epstein's brother so that that
has to be taken into account here Fox
and Friends then has a further interest
in perpetuating the most sensational and
salacious possible version of the story
but at the same time even people in our
audience who are not prone to
conspiratorial thinking email me every
few days and say David something here
doesn't seem right there are too many
coincidences he was on suicide watch and
then taken off and then the cameras go
down and the guards fall asleep and he
ends up with broken bones that never get
broken in a hanging suicide but and this
is what we all should be doing you've
got to start looking at these claims one
by one because a lot of times without
taking a side I want to be clear I don't
know what happened a lot of times when
you hear all these facts together it's
like wow yeah that clearly something
else happened but you gotta break him
down one by one
an example Baden says part of the
suspicious thing is he was on suicide
watch and then he was taken off of it
that's not really a part of the story
his own lawyers Epstein's own lawyers
asked for him to
be removed from suicide watch conditions
are not as good in suicide watch when
you were on suicide watch at this
particular facility so that's not really
part of what we're looking at his own
lawyer said take him off of suicide
watch
then there's the claim he says I've
never seen those bones broken in a
suicide well hold on a second I did a
very quick googling and found a study
called and there's many of these
fractures of the hyoid bone and thyroid
cartilage and suicidal hanging which
says that in this study in 25% of the
cases reviewed there were fractures of
the hyoid bone in known hanging suicides
so when Michael Baden says I've never
seen this well here's a study that says
it happens a quarter of the time it's
not proof of anything but again when he
says he's never seen it and that feels
overwhelming to us and then we say well
hold on here's an actual peer-reviewed
study which says it's not that rare this
one says it's happened in a quarter of
the times there are other studies which
say it's even more common that you see
fractures of the hyoid bone even in a
suicidal hanging so I don't know what
happened I'm not purporting to tell you
what happened I have an open mind and a
lot of this does seem weird and on
motive there are lots of people who
would want Epstein dead all I'm saying
is when you hear the bullet points
rattled off camera broken bones suicide
watch it sounds overwhelming and
uncontestable but when you start
breaking it down and looking at each
piece one by one a lot of these things
can be crossed off they can be crossed
off as proof or disproof they sort of
become not particularly relevant factors
and then you maybe can get a more sober
and sensible assessment of what went on
we may still never know what ultimately
happened but it's important to take
every single assertion with the same
skepticism that I hope I have inspired
people to have about any messages we
hear in media including those you hear
here on the David Pakman show let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show